こんにちははじめ社長です
3億円の新居だなひとりかくれんぼしても
見つからないぜたーーー
さあ奥の豪邸を呈しましたはじめ社長です
ただいまの時刻深夜の2時22分ひとり
かくれんぼという一種のなんか降霊術なの
かなこれがするという船怪奇現象に遭遇し
たという体験談が結構あるらしくて結構前
ですね僕の家でひとりかくれんぼやろうと
したんですけども中断しましてなぜかと
いうと普段絶対泣かない後編がなんか泣き
出してた馬って大丈夫本当に大丈夫かな
それぞれショップ
というかも
まずで売ってる
81なんてやめとこよねちょっと今回は
止めておきます始めた絶対やめてくださ
いって言ってなぜか中断さできなかったん
ですけどまぁ今回はチャー研の新居には
タックれられる場所が良い部屋強も
たくさん黄色でお部屋もあります小佐野系
の豪邸でひとりかくれんぼ失礼悪い例も
この立ち始めると見つけることができない
風の不成立ということで大あの
鳥肌が止まらないんですけどその満を持し
てひとりかくれんぼやってみたいと思い
ますいた説明していきましょう1人かけれ
ばの寸日するものです手足がある
ぬいぐるみ
米縫いバイトにと赤色が良い刃物コップ
一杯の塩水爪切り以上になりますこれは
仕様未をつくっちゃおうか瀬戸のほんじお
十分なよ入ったと思う恐怖っては早速やっ
ていきましょうまずは要求したぬいぐるみ
に名前をつけるでぬいぐるみを最低だから
またすべて取り出しますわかりました
そんな日だけど僕にはできないよ
全部取り出すんだねマジかもうこの時点で
普通に強いです
h 結構入ってなはい全部取り出しました
完璧です4コマでも産地になったじゃない
[音楽]
次はうーんに中に米を詰めると言います
ここ
[音楽]
本当にこれは[ __ ]
もうファンドになっちゃうんだってヤバ
イって爪を入れると自分の終わりました
紙よりもいいです
抜けた髪の毛いるんですけどだぞっ山芋
マニアバーン
まにゃ1な
年間ちゃん時までにやらないとぜってー
たいみたいな感じですよ今ですねちょっと
30なんですよこれ守るべきなのかなー
30ていうのいや俺さこういうの信じ
ちゃうんですよね
多分31分にあるとマジでやばい気がする
んでちょっと今日は準備だけしとくか
とりあえず髪の毛入れて赤い糸で咲いた
部分を縫いますと猫目は内臓を表していて
赤い糸は結果を表しているらしいです縫い
ます
[音楽]
言えたんですかはい縫えました準備完了
ですまたお風呂の水を張るとかあるんです
けどそれはちょっとまたばしたやります
かわいいな俺そういう高齢ずのルータ下
しっかり守るって何かあってからだと遅い
んでちゃんとは午前3時って何も持って
また後日であります
[音楽]
道
あ
[音楽]
食べられなるだれ本当にこれ本当に子は
ちょっと待って待って待って待って待って
終わったかちょっと待っていっ
あっはぁ
さあ3日前潜水死んだと思ってる先生
ねまったく課税価格たん
[音楽]
同2日目です今日めっちゃ楽しかったす
けど絶対入ろうと思って28分でござい
ますあと12分後にとにかく年もできる
ように準備していこうと思います
君の名前は
[音楽]
アンビシャス佐藤だ孤独な場合
アンビシャス佐藤です分かりづらいと思う
んですけどちゃんと赤い糸で縫ってえっと
北への爪と髪だけそしてお米入ってます
風呂場にあるフルーティに水を張っておく
お風呂場いきましょう
[音楽]
水貼りますねー
pou dou dou
だからオーナーが聞こえた気がしたんです
けど気のせいかん
tan
水張りました
あーやばいどこに隠れ a をかける場所
に
塩水置いとかなきゃいけないんでそれだけ
奇妙かあと1分でばい
シンプルに
シンプルバレなそうなと思います僕は
この辺にかけます
各種扉みたいなとこなんだけどここにかけ
ますあ
3時になりましたのでやっていきます
ぴったり止めていきます最初のには肇社長
だから最初のお庭はじめシャツのだから
最初のをには弾み雪のだから
取り合えばいい
風呂場に入ってぬいぐるみを見ずに張った
風呂下に入れますです
入れてきますもう始まってるんだよなぁ
もうやめれないよ
いません
プロのつきました
ってはアンヴィス砂糖
結果動きに入れます失礼します
入れましたーーー
変に戻ったら美術の明かりを消し
ok ここからテレビだけつけ力体日が
ないのでパソコンミュンターがいいと思っ
ているのでフェスイーズの的中していき
ます
ていた
全抜きましたネット次か
テレビはいもうモニターだけです森田だけ
になっています無理ただけにします
ああああああハーフ2
何時つもって換気扇
やはり落ち着きを実教実用実業ずつ計表示
付やるぞやるぞ目を閉じで10秒数えたら
刃物を持って再び風呂場に行く発達10秒
目つぶりますいきます
はい次が刃物を持って風呂場に行く
し行くぞ
これかぁ
いきますよ
うーむくらいから本当に無理ござい突然も
の大人から僕
終わります
ぶーなーるほ女優の枚替え
つきました
はい
the
いらっしゃいますねもうながら取りでき
ますねえ
ファンミ紗里を身につけた
次はアンビ佐藤が鬼だから
ねずみ次々杉瀬急ぎすぎ急げ急げ急ぎすぎ
3月いっしょ技術を削る
急げ急げ
水着次普通閣僚って書いてあったから
何だろうな泣きそうなんだろう
隠れます隠れます
[音楽]
んジョガー
各種の家なんで多分かくれんぼしてもバレ
ない
高齢している体はきっとヘア広すぎてどこ
ずんできない安全ひとりかくれんぼできる
かと思ってやっております
アメ車里はもうを見つけることができませ
ん
[音楽]
あればいいいつまでやればいいなこれ
バレないんだけど
[音楽]
んんん
にはないです
前回なんだよ
nan
何なんだもう
[音楽]
ん
th
ええええええ
私の勝ち
天気つい勉強する必要木
まあ
もう換気扇20が強くめくれちゃ
部 j
終わりましたモードロスター革命ずはいと
いうわけで無事
無事かはわかりませんがひとりかくれんぼ
儀式終了しますだ
ヘッド使ったあん bise 佐藤はヶ月
燃やして勝負しなきゃいけないという
ルールがありますすみませんがうまく表現
できないんですけども結構密封された変に
かけてたから音は分からなかったぜ全然で
もなんか見見せましたレポっぽいの結構
聞こえてその中建物的な騎士もうとより
大きいおくととかもう何度トリハダカっ
止まんないん
本当に誰かが探しているんだ俺のことを
っていう意識がすごくてちょっと7時間
あそこに色って言われたら僕はツン無理
でしたね本当に冗談抜きでいただければ
多分
[音楽]
見つかってないでしょうこの部屋この
3億円登って広いですからひとり
かくれんぼさとしても捕まらないぐらいの
広さがあることが今回証明されました
んあっ
[音楽]
はーる
el